sciences bonjour et bienvenue dans ce
direct du rallye de l'évolution l'espèce
qui remportera ce rallye se verra
attribuer le trophée l'évolution qui
récompensent l'espèce la plus évoluée et
voici maintenant les concurrents laisse
ces terribles reptiles vous fileront la
chair de poule
mr plume aiguisée ont fait trembler le
monde entier ce sont les dinosaures
ils ont le sang chaud mais la tête
froide et mouflons et c'est le poil ce
sont des hommes de faire des chiens à le
faire ce sont les mêmes faits petit mais
costaud au mou du dôme est dur en
affaires les
les avertir
pour la course je ne prenne pas signer
le carbure à l'énergie solaire vous y
accueillir comme il se doit le nom
attention le bas
3le c'est parti
ils sont partis sur les chapeaux de roue
au sérieux par loïc aussi appelé hier
primaire et ce sont les invertébrés qui
attaque fort dès le cambrien oui cet axe
très fort en même temps et c'est une
foisonnante diversité de formes aussi
extravagantes les unes que les autres
et parmi eux les trilobites règne sans
partage répondra devant tout le palais
rose ou ikea l'action mais si on met les
plans ne sont pas loin en effet il
semble que des abus ni cellulaire était
déjà présente il ya deux milliards
d'années vient d'avant les premiers
trilobé pizza nous arrivons à l'époque
de la sortie 10 août dernier les
ancêtres des dinosaures qui clame
également je suis content d'être à même
entré chez en me signalant régie que je
me sens pas uniquement les ancêtres des
philosophes qui ont coûté le milieu
aquatique
hariri en effet autant pour moi je
saurai d'ancêtre de tous les états
peuvent tiraient sur qui sortent des au
dévonien environ 360 millions d'années
au tampon et cela comprend donc aussi
bien les dinosaures que les amphibiens
ou même les mammifères ont mis que
vois-je pourquoi j'en fait usage d'un
spray et les plantes avaient déjà
conquis les milieux terrestres bien
avoir les tétrapodes délais sinon rien
tout à fait très cher et après tout cas
l'intérêt ignorer pour les têtes marc
david rochât sa femme s'il n'y avait pas
eu avant g de sucre est associé un
champignon sous forme de week-end
l'équipe l'an 2000 il a certainement
fêter toute incursion sur terre bien
avant cette date les concurrents attaque
maintenant la période de mai
joli coup ère secondaire on ne déplore
aucune sortie leurs auteurs et tous
tournés les négocier sans faute cash de
dire à celle de l'écrit ci dernière
triage une performance extraordinaire
malgré des perdus vont atteindre jusqu'à
90 % des espèces comme les invertébrés
aquatiques
je pense très cher que je mettrai tout
le monde d'accord en disant que le
mésozoïque a été sans conteste la
période du règne sans partage des
dinosaures
certaines mais les plants avaient déjà
pris une belle avance en donnant
naissance à des formes généreuses den
camani sert que de 50 millions d'années
avant l'apparition premiers dinosaures
porter les orienter ortega les lentes et
en europe et les invertébrés de son fort
manque de ressources puisqu'ils
reprennent une belle accélération après
la crise et deviennent les maîtres du
domaine marin grâce aux ammonites mais
attendez attendez il me semble que de
nous arrêter là avant avait non
saucisson de mes films marin des
reptiles géants ou non de dinosauriens
que la lure à hastings acte était grec
comme le confirme en régie les marins ne
sont pas des dinosaures c'est donc une
belle occasion manquée de prendre une
belle avance
de leur côté les mammifères semblent
souffrir d'une avarie technique qu'elle
ait des ennuis
bien que leur ligne et sont apparus en
même temps que celle des dinosaures il
ya 13 300 millions d'années
il semble qu'ils aient beaucoup moins
bien supporté la crise n'a rien triage
ils ont du plomb dans le moteur les
mammifères ils auront du mal à remonter
le peloton
et oui mais s'est étonné rémois très
vite leur carburant mais aussi quand on
sait le prix aussi bien en mode de vie
aquatique au vol plané au mais que
vois-je est extraordinaire dans la
dernière ligne droite avant la fin du
mésozoïque de magnifiques tous ses
conjointes à des insectes et des
végétaux mais miss et la permission de
la pollinisation en parfaite
coordination il invente les plantes à
fleurs et les insectes pollinisateurs
c'est incroyable
oh mais regardez là bas les dinosaures
évolue encore et crétacé c'est l'époque
des géants très belle offensive de la
part des dinosaures qui voit alors leur
forme et plus célèbres apparaître comme
les grands carnivores
carcharodontosaures russie spinosaurus
signé encore celui qu'on ne présente
plus le si les razzias
c'est vraiment très agressif que nous
propose ces dinosaures du très très beau
sport les mammifères vont-ils se
contenter de ce qu'il est sortie en
rente hilarant splendide action
humanitaire qui profitent de ce sursaut
de diversité des oiseaux rien pour en
manger quelques-uns au passage c'est
pour ma part je sais j'ai servi et c'est
aussi haut que tu as et qu'apparaissent
les premiers représentants des familles
de mammifères classe affaires et
mellifères ne se laisse pas de vent
c'est comme ça attention car les
concurrents s'approche maintenant de
dangereux virage de la crise 4 et
attention ça va être très serré pour
tout le monde à dos renversant mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe
ce hors des routes c'est une sorte
d'aura l'écran que le contrechoc fini
pour eux c'est l'hécatombe pour tout le
monde même les mammifères et les plantes
les algues aussi en prennent tous pour
leur grade
heureusement pour certains de se dé son
écharpe ou même quelques ruelles fin
cours tout de même pour cette formidable
dinosaures mais la course continue
notamment pour l'imaginaire qui
profitent de la disparition des grands
et petits venir opérer une avancée
colossal elle a tapé lors d'un service
diversifie et s'adapte au milieu aérien
terrestre et aquatique ont bien donné
que vois-je c'est extraordinaire c'est
formidable c'est exceptionnel ce sont
les dinosaures les dinosaures qui
reviennent
le
j'étais toujours un groupe jusqu'à leur
dise que des agents remontent le peloton
oui mais moi c'est incroyable remontée
avec une vitesse ahurissante de
naissance appelée de deux fois plus que
de manière tout à fait mais vont-ils
tenir la rencontre face à leurs
concurrents les mammifères je n'en suis
pas atteint et bien détrompez vous cale
sa nature car émissaire auprès bien sûr
nous y est
ninja ninja ninja il y avait 600 comptes
et justes dans la dernière ligne droite
jusqu'à la fin du cénozoïque
l'apparition dans le vent des mammifères
des premières espèces intelligentes les
êtres humains toutefois je crains que
cette poignée je l'assumé de fasse pas
le poids devant les lions remporte ainsi
un million de ce ces pertes auriez
certainement 30 fois plus restreint
découvrir et tout débarque pour m'y
invite jusque dans une maison en effet
tâche est extrêmement serré tout ça va
se jouer à la faute au regard de mon
concurrent concurrents a fait son
apparition il est en train de faire une
remontée incroyable comme je crois qu'il
s'agit
rory c'est ça la régie me dis qu'il
s'agit de bactéries
eh bien pas de traitement il n'ya
production
rené cet énorme il n'avait même pas vu
démarrer une rente
certaines d'entre elles luciano patrie
sont les premiers organismes apparentés
dont on a des traces fossiles datés de
plus nos trois milliards d'années et
c'est grâce à l'activité de ces
bactéries que notre atmosphère contient
de l'oxygène
mais il ya des milliards d'années les
parties deviennent indispensables aux
autres organismes vivants est devienne
émules tout qu'on dit est essentielle à
la respiration et les chloroplastes des
plantes essentielle pour la faune tous
en selle mais si certaines vous permet
de vivre d'autres points dont vous
terrassé en un clin d'oeil comme la
peste par exemple dit mais costaud foot
par les invités c'est une stratégie très
offensive que vous en fera voir là et ce
n'est pas fini de 500 des figurants
puisque ce qu'on appelle communément les
plaques eric recours en fait d'un
embranchement de l'année entière elle
seule les bactéries et les orques et
materi et oui tout à fait sophie sont
tellement diversifiée que leur code
génétique et plus différents l'un de
l'autre que le nôtre mais l'est de celui
des plantes ou même des champignons rien
ne semble pouvoir les arrêter et non et
surtout pas le bouillant tout même
encore des doses de radioactivité qui
nous des rats serait vague qui
s'accommode de tout même des métaux
comme le mercure et lors de certaines
espèces sont capables de métaboliser et
c'est maintenant le moment du sprint
final
d
une parfaite égalité que nous appelons
toutes les passions sur la plus haute
marche du podium
qu'apporte-t-il années de bush d'être
intelligente alors qu'elles vont pas
moins de 500 de quinze jours à peine
après sa naissance ses lauriers aux
meilleurs nageurs qu'un crocodile quand
vous avez le sang chaud et pas lui nous
avons tous parcouru autant de chemin et
évolutif depuis notre dernière ancêtre
commun une cellule ludique qui vivait il
ya presque 4 milliards d'années et j'ai
dit cela c'est donc devenu un baptême
sur son propre terrain il n'a plus
évolué il n'y a pas d'espèces 2000 note